welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and with the boys
bowing out with one of the best season
finales i've ever seen
in in a long time we have a lot to talk
about
throughout this video we're going to be
going through the full final episode
and discussing all the easter eggs and
things you missed
as always there will be heavy spoilers
here and if you haven't seen the episode
yet then i highly recommend that you
turn off now
make sure you drop a thumbs up if you've
enjoyed the coverage and don't forget to
subscribe for more boys breakdowns
throughout the next couple of weeks
without the way thank you for clicking
this let's get into the breakdown
okay so the finale opens on a video that
aims to teach kids how to survive a
super villain attack at school
throughout we're guided by homelander
and sheriff ed flanagan as they go
through the three steps of lock
arm and weight or law for short
i think this is actually a parody of how
to survive a school shooting
by lawson university who recently posted
this video online
and similar to what we see in the show
gave us three steps
these were avoid deny and defend which
is similar to what homelander and co
advise you to take now you may remember
that when school shootings were more
prevalent in the u.s
that president trump suggested arming
teachers as a safety precaution
this is being carried across here but as
we know from what we've seen in the show
guns would likely be pretty useless
against most of the supervillain power
set
similar to the lawson university video
homelander says that someone will be
dispatched to help
however whereas in the real world
version it was the police
in the boys universe it's a
quote-unquote hero
as we know from both the show and comic
books the seven and vote heroes are
actually pretty useless when it comes
down to it
and this has been demonstrated in the
playing scene in which both homelander
and maeve
couldn't really do anything this video
also has a website link
however upon visiting this nothing comes
up which is a bigger letdown than my
parents
now things quickly pick up in the
episode and we jump across to the
aftermath of the attack last week
a national emergency is about to be
declared by the president
and he's authorized compound v for use
by the authorities
now though victoria newman states that
it was bored who carried out zaku
we actually learned that it was her
behind it the entire time
now victoria newman is actually based on
the comic book character
vic the veep who in the source material
was a vote puppet
that the corporation were trying to get
into the white house so that they would
be able to overrule any potential laws
that could be passed against them
by the end of the entry it does seem
like vic is indeed going after the
presidency
and we end with her getting appointment
in congress much like aoc who the
character is satirizing
you might remember that in our episode 4
breakdown we mistakenly said that in the
comics viktor veep was a soup himself
and it's kind of crazy that that mistake
actually came true in the long run
as it's a massive diversion from the
source material i was sure that it was
cindy behind the attack
and she'll likely be coming back in the
third season to potentially expose what
we're up to
i should have really guessed it was
victoria as amazon even reached out to
me about four weeks ago
asking if i'd be up for interviewing her
after the season
as she was going to be part of its
ending it seems kind of obvious looking
back that they were gearing her up to be
something
important but hey i'm pretty stupid
maybe you should have been watching
someone else's breakdowns
but it's too late now we're at the
finale no but you'll likely want to know
what vic's plan was this entire time
and if we piece it all together it seems
like she wanted to get be released to
the public through the means of
escalation
because of the soups vort clearly had an
advantage over not only the public
but the government itself and thus she
carried out this false flag attack in
order to make it seem like wart was
behind it
so that the power's her end would
receive b now that her congressional
race has gone to plan
she will likely gain access to far more
of this stuff and will also have a say
in who gets it and who doesn't
stormfront's plan this entire time was
to give it to a certain group of people
so that she could create a master race
and i kind of have the feeling that vic
will also be selective in who gets it
and who doesn't
recently there's been a lot of talk that
this once almost central show
has been leaning heavily to the left
however i do think with the overarching
plot motif of this
that it's shown everything simply isn't
as black and white as we would believe
vic takes out aleister adana at the end
of the episode and this is likely to
gain access to the blackmail material
that the church has on board
so that she has one more thing that she
can hold over their heads
at no point in the series have i really
seen her as the villain
and it was a nice surprise to see that
she was actually the emperor palpatine
to this entire thing
without the obvious foreshadowing now we
discover the pentagon has an order in
as well as ice the organization that are
tasked with maintaining the us border
there's definitely a feeling of
increased military might and we watch
becca escaping the board facility
before we cut immediately to the army
patrolling the streets and suvs
annie is also wearing a camouflage
t-shirt and though
very subtle i think it's subliminally
lacing the scene with a lot of military
iconography
that's a complete reach i must admit now
annie gives her mother her goodbyes
and she gives her a cross necklace in
exchange this of course has ties to her
past
as well as her comic origins and the
young americans
a teen titans parody of which she was a
member she journeys back to the boys
base
as we see them prep to take down anyone
that comes into their path
mallory has tasked them with getting
another witness that can bring down vote
from the inside
but they see that as pretty pointless
and just want to mow down the supes and
he asks for one day
in which he can get someone else and she
heads out with huey to get help from
maeve
a fleetwood mac and concert t-shirt can
be seen on huey
and this is following on from the motif
of his journey japan 81 concert from
last time the character has of course
also worn several items related to billy
joel throughout the season
and so far five of his songs have
appeared in the series
these include pressure you're only human
we didn't start the fire
and the entry this episode only the good
die young
i really hope that isn't a reference to
stormfront as well
which also just so happens to be the
name of an album by joel
we actually learn why huey holds the
artist so dearly and aside from having
complete bangers
it was also his mother's favorite singer
she
she's not dead though don't worry she
just left when he was six
now who knows if she will actually pop
up again and if you have a theory on why
she left out of the blue
then let me know in the comments below
now if you cast your mind back to the
first season
huey was actually talking about billy
joel to robin before she was completely
flattened by a train
i think that he may constantly go back
to him because the singer reminds him of
a time before his life went to hell
back at vote tower we see the wreckage
left in the aftermath of black noir vs
starlight
the room is being reconstructed and we
learn that noir is unresponsive
meaning he might be a vegetable but it's
hard to tell which
hey you know another joke i appreciate
now i actually have a theory that noir
might become the first soup who is
revived with compound b
and that this will turn him into a
zombie-like character in the comics v
was actually capable of bringing the
dead back to life due to it firing up
the neurons in the brain
and this left the person on the
receiving end of it in a zombie-like
state
thought paraded the person around and
lied to the public
telling some wild comic book-like story
about how they'd come back from the dead
and this was to make it seem like their
superheroes were invincible
i can see that sort of being carried
across with noir and i would love to see
this riff on the comics as it does seem
like they're moving away from what
happens to him in the source material
homelander come to the conclusion that
it might have been edgar behind the
attack last week
and stormfront says that he's pretty
smart especially for his kind
this further shows how she views other
races and she also states she has a
solution to stop
certain people getting v i think that
this might be a play on the final
solution from the second world war
annie and hughie arrive at maeve's and
ask for her help but she rejects their
plea to testify against fort
she does end up saving the day later on
but because
vote are not publicly brought down by
someone speaking out it doesn't seem
like their rain will be ending anytime
soon so yeah homelander you can just
keep on doing what you want i guess
now at the church of the collective we
see the meeting that adana mentioned
last week with wart's ceo stan edgar
he refuses to have a fresca and calls it
awful stuff
though we still don't know what's going
on with it i think he probably knows
what's really up with the drink and thus
doesn't have any of it
the pair discussed the deep getting back
in the seven and we learned that
after the church rebuild the image of a
fallen soup they get a cut of the profit
eagle the archer likely didn't want to
be part of this
and this is why he was cast out after
speaking with his mother on the matter
edgar accepts the deep but denies a
train's return
stating that bringing back one is
redemption whereas accepting two would
be seen as a weakness
this line later appears in the episode
when a train is accepted back instead of
the deep
and the roles are reversed but why does
he get taken back exactly
and not the lovable character the deep
well after overhearing this meeting
namely the bar that stormfronts racism
is the thing stopping him from getting
back in
a train hands over the files on her to
huey and annie
they used this to expose the character
and vault would have obviously removed
her
had what happened not happened at the
boy's base
becca arrives asking for help and she's
given a lovely french baguette
billy calls out to edgar and ends up
meeting him to discuss getting a hold of
ryan
so that the company have something to
hold over homeland is head
in the comics the contingency plan for
the antagonist was actually black noir
and if you want to learn more about the
ins and outs of this then definitely
check out our video on the character
which will be linked at the end now ryan
does get taken at the end by billy
and the cia and thus this is likely why
we see the character
choking the chick into the city they
actually do a great job of showing how
attached homeland it becomes to his son
and back at boar tower he decides to
spend some quality time with him
we actually get a lot of father and son
moments in this episode
and see a completely different side to
the villain at several points
i even forgot that he was a complete
psychopath with the ability to burn
everything around him to the ground and
deep down
i kind of wish he was my dad now after
being sworn by fans he actually puts
ryan before his image
and also sits down and discusses how he
was filled with fear growing up too
it's by far the most vulnerable that
we've ever seen him
i think anthony starr deserves a lot of
praise for how he handles the character
in this episode
i also love how ashley's hair is still
falling out from all the stress
and we first saw this on the set of the
seven movie after homeland tried to do
some damage control for killing an
innocent bystander
now back to edgar and his plan i think
it's probably
the thing in the show that i have the
biggest problem with
i'm not sure it makes that much sense
and it seems like it was always gonna go
one way with stormfront
looking at things in hindsight edgar
hired stormfront because
he knew she would make people angry and
thus they would want compound b
which would drive up the company's stock
price i think that they could have just
brought in someone to do the exact same
job without her trying to create her own
master race
and the super terrorist threat would
have driven up the need for v anyway
edgar has had to bite his tongue as she
slammed the company
and he states that lashing out is a
white man's luxury
thus he needs billy to do his dirty work
and the two agree to separate ryan from
homelander so that ball can come in and
pick him up
billy ultimately betrays becca's trust
and this does lead to her death which i
think the character is going to have to
live with
he swears on his brother lenny's soul
that he won't let ryan grow up with fort
but a lot of the tragedies could have
been avoided you also see kimiko
folding to orissaroos definitely
butchered the pronunciation on that
anyway in japanese culture these are
meant to represent the carrying of one
spirit to the afterlife
and it is likely that she's done this
for her brother who was killed by
stormfront earlier in the season
cut to homeland as wood cabin and you
might remember that this appeared
earlier in the series when he was em
who he was pleasuring himself he tells
ryan about the first time that he was in
a crowd
and also tries to get him to use his
laser on a figure of the deep
stormfront fills his head with the idea
of white genocide which is a conspiracy
theory held by extremists that believe
other isis are trying to wipe out whites
through infertility higher abortion
rates and the end of white immigration
ryan believes what she says i think this
is a comment on how children are not
born prejudiced
but they tend to grow up that way after
being influenced by elders
just as ryan is about to use his hate to
burn the deep figure
stormfront gets a notification that the
truth about her has been leaked to the
web
and she flies away to board tower just
in the way that she used the internet as
a weapon against
fort the internet has struck back and
there's several memes in videos about
her that bring her public image down
with her out of the way the boys enact
their plan and using supersonics they
set off high pitched frequencies which
infect both homelander and ryan's
hearing
i think this is a reference to the dark
knight returns and in that batman
actually used a supersonic gun
in order to momentarily disable superman
so that he could attack him
homelander flies out to find the source
of the sound and becca rushes to ryan
which i think is where billy has a
change of heart after seeing the two
together
he decides to leave behind the phone
that both security are using to track
them
and he tries to send the pair off to
mallory however stormfront arrives
and homelander goes back to the cabin to
find the wart team there
he quickly works out what's going on and
decides to enact
laser eye surgery on people's skulls
massacring them all
now the fight with stormfront is not
only awesome
but it also has several callbacks to the
comics kimiko says that she's going to
stick her boot up her nazi kitty
and in the source material we watch his
stormfront literally get someone's foot
up his arse
stormfront also states in the work that
he can't be blinded and this leads to
the female
aka the comic book version of kimiko
brutally blinding him
it massively messes up his eyes similar
to what we see here
however it is changed slightly and it's
becca that does it instead of kimiko
now i loved seeing the characters
starting to resemble her comic book
counterpart
and this reveal was probably my favorite
part of the episode
they also pay off the girls get it done
joke in an amazing way
by having maeve join the fight and we
see as they stomp her out in a scene
that's very in line with the original
work in the forest
billy becker and ryan run for it but
stormfront catches up to them
after she pins becca to a tree ryan
unleashes his laser beams which
completely rip both women apart
sadly killing his mother it's a big big
death
and it kind of brings things back to the
status quo in the comics
butch's wife was actually dead and thus
this death year
lines up more with the work than the
reveal at the end of season 1.
in her dying moments becca makes billy
promise her
that ryan owes her death isn't his fault
throughout the season
her biggest worry has been that he ends
up growing up like his father
and in the supplementary material on the
show we did learn that homelander killed
his quote-unquote mother when he was a
child
now homelander was raised in a lab
however he gravitated towards a nurse
that he called his mum
and one day he accidentally broke her
spine by hugging her too hard
it's likely the straw that broke the
camel's back and becca needs to know
that the same thing won't happen with
ryan
homelander arrives and finds stormfront
looking like anakin skywalker
and speaking german i don't speak german
myself so i have no idea what she says
but let me know if you do as i am quite
curious to know
now we don't actually see stormfront die
and it could also be possible that she
returns in an almost zombie-like state
down the line
as we haven't seen the full extent of
what b is capable of
that probably won't happen but you never
know how the shows can go
now ryan sides with billy and homelander
is completely broken by the revelation
that his son doesn't love him
just as homelander is about to rip him
apart maeve arrives with the footage of
the flight the two refused to save
and she uses homelanders ego against him
homelander doesn't have a weakness per
se
but when discussing the character
anthony stars stated that his need to be
loved
was what drove him and this fragility
means that he can be controlled
maeve will expose him as the monster he
is and though
initially he doesn't seem like he wants
this to happen
by the end of the episode i kind of get
the feeling that he doesn't really care
anymore
now i do believe that the blood on his
face and the confrontation with maeve is
actually a reference to the comics
in the original work when homelander
killed her he had a similar looking face
but i think they've flipped it here as
many people including myself did think
in the trailers that this was going to
happen at this moment
i was also going to put the stormfront
thing as the thumbnail over this
but didn't really want to spoil anything
so you kids that see my videos before
you watch the episode
you better bloody count yourself lucky
now edgar publicly denounces stormfront
and she gets the blame for the attack at
the hearing last week we also see annie
back in her former costume
and you may remember that she was forced
to change it in the comics the
corporation wanted to sex her up a bit
and thus they made her show more skin
but the fact she's back in the more
formal one
does hint that things could be heading
in a new direction
at the church alistair reveals that he
knows the stormfront league came from a
train
and because of this he's been let back
into the seven again
the deep is absolutely hilarious in this
scene and he steps back from the church
after they say he's not allowed back
with the group they further hammer home
the church in scientology connections
by saying he had to marry some weirdo
who gives
terrible jobs and they also have the
deep mention that the religion believes
they are space spores
which mirrors scientology and the theme
levels
annie and huey may add a park bench and
discuss their relationship
whilst also going into what path the
future will have for them
the iconography has been echoed
throughout the series as well as the
comics
and benches have been a central meeting
place for the pair
it's a really summer moment and we
learned that annie will try and change
things from the inside at bought
whilst huey will start to work for
victoria newman which we'll get into in
just a bit
billy says goodbye to ryan and then
hands him over to the cia
all the charges against spelly have been
dropped and mallory has been put as the
head of superhero affairs
she asks if billy wants to work with her
which will likely be what the third
season centers around
mother's milk returns to his daughter
with a giant penguin toy
kimako and frenchie agree to go dancing
together and pretty much everyone
gets a happy ending we catch homelanders
standing on the cries of the building
giving his uh all to new york
i know this is a strange scene it's
actually sort of playing on the comics
though not as graphic in the source
material there was a point where the
characters sat overlooking the city
saying i can do anything now bit of
trivia here
but this scene was actually meant to be
in the first season
however it was cut by amazon for being
too over the top
i don't know why they had a change of
heart but i'm glad that they allowed it
back in
as it's the perfect way to say goodbye
to him you can actually
read the description of their cutscene
online and it does seem
beat for beat exactly the same though in
the original version
it had the context of coming after
stillwell had just put him in his place
so yeah good to see it here i guess and
we end with huey
working for newman after she's appointed
in congress
i think going forward huey will announce
that she was actually the one behind the
super attack
and because of her position in society
he will be forced to go on the run once
more with help from the boys
homelander obviously wants to take her
down too and it's gonna be
really interesting to see how things
head out from here
we also see her banner which says for
the people and this is of course because
she's got v for the people
but whether that turns out to be a good
thing or not remains to be seen
now we also know that the seven are
short of few members and though a train
is back to replace shockwave
it does leave things up in the air for
what's gonna happen to stormfront's
replacement
well after the public learned the truth
about her i think that vault will want
to balance out her origin
with some all-american justice this will
lead to the appointment of soldier boy
who's a hero that's basically just
satirizing captain america
we already know he's confirmed for the
third season so i think it makes a lot
of sense that he will slot in the place
of stormfront
and also slot in the place of
homelanders but
spoiler alert there anyway that's the
episode
the season and our breakdown and i just
want to give a huge thank you for all
your support over the last month
i've seen a massive amount of comments
and subscriptions
and it's made doing these breakdowns
even easier so i massively appreciate it
as i said we still have a lot to talk
about so make sure you stay locked
to the channel for more boys coverage
before we move on to the mandalorian at
the end of the month
if you missed out on video on the black
noir theory then definitely check it out
after this
as the yeah there's just so much to talk
about
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat on the discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video you
been the best
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you